do you have any weapons in the car or
anything like that with a gun or
anything
okay I'm 19 years old
if this is going to cause problems and
the truck's over there I'm just gonna
take out the best and I'm from Tennessee
so are you wearing the best like I said
I drove from all the way from Tennessee
but I'm not gonna I'm not gonna have
people call me
when I don't even live in this damn
State okay it's gonna piss me off you're
you're a deputy sheriff well I mean I
work at the Sheriff's Office okay I mean
what were you a corrections officer for
the Sheriff's Office okay why do you
wear a vest outside of the facility
vehicle or is this your personal vehicle
this is from Ikea okay
it's just a little odd because whenever
I worked in the jail
I took my crap off especially if I was
taking a long drive from Tennessee
that's the same thing I have been
pulling up with so many times on
Tennessee and Arkansas right okay they
know I have told them everything that
might not be true but
four two wearing this stuff I mean like
it every time I come up here I mean they
don't all they say is it's just odd I
never see it right well I mean like well
guess what I like wearing it just like
in Tennessee I've got four of them for
you guess what yeah I'm not saying it's
against the law or anything it's just
and I think the dad had took it off and
I've had it set right here before and
they're like and I get I get yelled at
four there's like you know it's kind of
weird that you got your belt and your
belt got any kind of employment
identification dude they don't give me
that when you work at the deal really
you don't have like an access card or ID
badge or anything for the facility that
you work at I don't I can exactly my
face though
the whole thing online
oh so my only deal is
there you go yeah are you commissioned
to carry a gun
wait you realize we're in the sheriff on
your chest
is basically impersonating law
enforcement is that whether or not
you're carrying a gun
okay but are you commissioned to be
carrying a gun and do you have arrest
power
that's beside the fact you're wearing a
patch that says Sheriff okay
that's impersonating law enforcement I'm
worried all the time at the jail before
though okay well that might be true and
fine within the gel but when you come
out to public you don't have any arrest
Powers you don't you're not commissioned
do you understand I understand
and you got alcohol in the vehicle well
it's not mine well that's beside the
point it's my girlfriend and I don't
drink so it doesn't it doesn't matter
you realize transporting open container
if any of that's opened or partially uh
missing that it doesn't matter whose it
is if you're in the vehicle with it you
can be arrested for uh transporting open
container well I mean like I said it's
it's not I literally
she bought it you she lives up there in
Luther have you ever heard the phrase
when guys get hemmed up for drugs in
their pockets and they say these pants
aren't mine you realize
okay so let's let's stop saying it all
right okay
I'm not from here so all right
but there's proof right there but like I
tell them I just want to take it off
that's fine I'd much rather you just
take the sheriff patch off I mean I
could do that
because if you're if you're not
commissioned to be a sheriff's deputy or
a police officer
I am a deputy sheriff yes but I'm trying
to be nice I understand why you got
called but right but if you walk around
with
a best carrier on with sheriff on your
chest and you're not sure you may work
for the sheriff's office but you work in
a jail and you're not commissioned
outside of the jail to carry a gun or
have any arrest Powers okay all right
but I told him I'll just take it off
because okay I'm not from here
I'm not trying to cause any problems
okay
this is your command at where you work
at know that you decide to go around in
the public put the vest on with the
sheriff on your chest
s
but you wear it anyways well I'm tired
you wear it to drive all the way from
Tennessee to Choctaw Oklahoma
right either way
I've had this happen for me
performance and they've let me go they
just don't have to wear okay my biggest
issue is the sheriff on your
yeah however long it was to get down
here it's not a good interaction for us
to know you that you're wearing your
stuff outside of work
especially up here with my mom so I
could be a cop up here because she lives
up here and I'm trying I'm trying to be
a cop but in your 19th yeah but they
won't let me they don't I've already put
up pictures
I still got residents down there
Tennessee obviously right now I got an
address what were you going to Oklahoma
City for huh what are you headed to
Oklahoma City for
I'm going to 122 Northwest Street what
are you what are you doing
apartment you live there no my mom does
okay I was just curious I mean I'm not
trying to cause any trouble man okay
like I told him
I'm just trying to move up here
hopefully if I can I get the money right
now yeah I'm just trying to come see her
for New Year man that's it right
I really don't want did she used to live
in Tennessee or did you move out to
Tennessee or what's the deal on that why
she live here and you live in Tennessee
oh okay so you live in Tennessee where
your dad lives or whatever okay
hello all right okay
so did you get out of your car or
something here in the parking lot okay I
got out of the car yeah there's a truck
that he looked at me that's all I did I
never I never never said anything like
wise or nothing he looked at me and he
was laughing so I just like go to his
car and I was like
if someone says that's it and I just
like walked away okay I mean I don't
I just foreign
and you don't have a gun with you or
anything like that
I can search the car
I mean is that what you said
you asked me if I had a gun man I was
just asking if you had a gun on you no I
can search the car you don't mind if I
search the car I don't think okay cool
step on out if you don't mind
all right
let's drop your cord there
all right place the vehicle and I'll
just check you for make sure you don't
have any guns or nothing
all right
if you wouldn't mind go ahead and take
the best off and just set it in the car
thank you
so do you wear this vest carrier on duty
in the jail I mean like I can so I
usually wear it under my hood okay
what vehicle was it you
stop to talk to I didn't stop at MLP you
know I mean he said that you stopped and
thought you talked to me I mean some in
some drug but then he left out of the
parking lot okay but all I did is
literally I went up let's go get the
vest off for me
and the only reason I'm having you take
it off the code
I don't have to worry about the knives
or anything you may have on you
that's fine I mean I've seen a lot worse
all right if you'll just go
sit on the curb up there
yeah that's fine
okay we'll just check everything out if
everything's good then we'll
we'll go on
why don't we go have a seat in my Tahoe
I don't have a seat in my taco
are you on the phone that's my
girlfriend
okay let me hang up the phone we can't
have people in the back seat with all
those
thanks
tonight
251.
[Music]
thank you
okay so RP says he didn't actually see
anybody can stop and talk to anybody
like oh okay he just he was he was
parked boxed into a parking spot
you seen the kid walking around in the
parking lot a little bit
looked over at him they kind of made eye
contact with me and he started kind of
giggling because the way he was acting
he looked inside of his car like
he was looking for something they've got
in her country kind of traffic they got
out and came over to his truck and was
like what's so funny what are you doing
or you know just being shot with ass
right and then goes well I was making a
traffic stop and you're over here
and then two more to go and he it was a
pack of six
all right
just all kinds of red flags man
I would not drive from Tennessee with
the best carry on no or even a duty belt
on as soon as I get off I take that shit
off I'm tired of being in it I hate
driving from Topgolf to my house with
this shit on
the least amount of time that I can
spend in this thing uh the better and
his vest doesn't even feel like it has
any kind of
Temple or anything in it
I asked him if he were bored at work
he's acted like it would it wouldn't be
a big deal if he wore it at work but
then like okay do you or do you not
it does have a Templar thing in here
that's supposed to be the rear and it's
on the front
there's more of this for you
yep it could be
[Music]
my lieutenant uh so
pretty much he he had to have
attempted to act like law enforcement
like trying to make a traffic stop uh
[Music]
but as far as just saying something to
somebody wearing what he's saying or
wearing what he's wearing is I guess not
it's not it's kind of protected type
thing yeah yeah he he hadn't he didn't
really cross the law yet
but he's he's walking the Fine Line yeah
yeah that I mean
man
fucking I even went to go buy a patch at
the place on Douglas yeah top team top
tier yeah and they wanted to verify
who I was I mean because they don't want
to be associated with someone buying
shit that isn't law enforcement
it's he's already checked out he's got
no warrants no want I wonder if he's got
any uh some car chase back to him yeah
supervisor contact that we could talk to
a supervisor
we'll put his
patch back on
I got a picture of his ID and stuff
I mean I got him on video wearing it so
do you like I'm sure
wearing what looks like dress beautiful
pants yeah
and he says the alcohol is his
girlfriend yeah that's what he told me
to I was like well
even if it's your girlfriends if you're
transporting an open container that's
against the law it doesn't matter whose
it is yeah
I don't want to run the kid I mean
see if he'll give us a contact number
for a supervisor at work or something
I'm gonna shut this other door
I wouldn't worry about the jail thing
right now
with the beer car like I said that it's
not in my possession right it is in your
position in your car by you owning the
vehicle and being in your vehicle in the
city beside you that is considered in
position
I'm gonna try I mean
oh
we're not looking to take you to jail
but we're not looking we want to talk to
a supervisor here
I don't care if you take it I mean okay
that'll keep me out of trouble we want
to talk to a supervisor
in your phone all right almost
stand up here
and it's Campbell County
oh shit
I washed my best last night and I left
all that
oh
that has been working like too long
like you haven't been to work in two
weeks
[Music]
so you haven't been to work in two weeks
but you're wearing the
uniform pants Duty style looking shoes
and a vest carrier well I mean like I'm
trying to go back to work but
I mean they're my cousins are doing
it
well it's it's it's kind of a process to
get tired
right but Oklahoma I've only called and
they're like
they're not Edmond hired once a year
yeah and you gotta have a bachelor's
degree
I mean
yeah Edmond has kind of high standards
you got to have a bachelor's degree
but I've I've fallen everywhere
yeah it's just weird to me that you
weren't even recently on duty and you're
wearing the best carrier
where'd you get the best carrier from
did you order it online no
from a friend
at a store it's a police store up there
in Knoxville Tennessee
I bought it like four months ago
I mean you can you can take all this
stuff
okay I mean that's I don't care I mean I
bought all this stuff none of that stuff
was given to the counter so it ain't
like I saw it okay all right give me a
come back
okay so I'm not gonna see your DPS all
right cool
hey can you transfer me to a number
uh four two three four nine four
nine seven three six
foreign
yes this is definitely Mike Hanson with
the Oklahoma County Sheriff's Office I'm
out on a individual saying he works for
uh Campbell County Sheriff's Office
by the name of Jackson Jones you'll give
me a call back
[Music]
405-869-2501-2501 that is our dispatch
number and they can have you transport
transfer to all right
so it went to a voicemail so that's like
not an official
work number
is a lot
oh yeah
all zeros
and it was in messenger
yeah he said he was his brother but he
says but if you read the fact what's
your phone number Jacob Lynn Jones
says right here
right there okay I'll put you down
so I don't know again
Jacob actually works in jail but it
doesn't sound like he actually does
unless he got hired on with him watching
Washington
what was what county was it Campbell
County
that's what his check stuff showed
this is dated
11 18 and 22.
for Jackson Jones
Campbell County government Sheriff's
Department
124 Cumberland
that's not even the same address for him
it appears he had once that's that
wasn't yeah recently had
employment there
are eight four grand so judge right
yeah
all right tell me exactly what you just
said
because he was dressed like a cop he had
a sheriff's thing but he had shrimp
written on the side right right and I
live on 62 off of Adam Road he was
sitting in a driveway 251 yeah
Highway and I pulled up and I was
staring at him because he was in there
kind of Buckeye and I was like we live
on a one one way in one way out and you
know wellers are watching for cars and I
sat there and I was staring at him and I
started about 10 minutes of staring at
him and I'm like hey he's this guy it's
kind of odd and our neighbor's driveway
I sit there stared at him stare at him
and I drove off he got right behind me
truck oh
and uh he was driving along he was right
on my right Army and I was like
this is from over by the hair actor from
there all the way down so always
he gets out and I said can I help you
sir he's like well uh
I was wondering what was your problem
you're staring at me over the in the
driveway and I said yeah I was kind of
curious to see you what because that's
kind of odd that uh I know who you was I
was kind of curious I lived down the
road I was trying to see what's going on
and I was staring at you see who he was
he goes I'm a I'm a undercover cop
for Wellston
and I run my partner I run with the
highway patrolman uh Western
okay okay and I said so uh just because
you look pretty young how old are you
because I'm 22 years old just turned 22.
I was like Hey we're gonna be a cop be
an investigator right and uh I said uh
what brings to me a cop is it like
getting a family or whatever you know
try to just talk to him
yeah
I love my family from cops and stuff
that's because I became about my big
team and then uh he goes uh well I got a
call I gotta let you go and then he left
and then when he left he came towards uh
by the uh bridge on uh Turnpike bridge
and he took you eat and we're trying to
pull him another car he was trying to
pass his life at him really and I don't
know if they pulled over or not but he
was past his lights like he was trying
to pull him over I was like
right I got home that's why I go and
tell my wife I like it oh this car
pulled me over and I was talking to this
guy and I was trying to see it it feels
oh yeah because we got a cop friend that
lives in Wellston I'm gonna call him
later on when he wakes up to see it
tonight he works nicely to see if he's
really that guy his odd out he was
acting I got you can you hang out here
for a minute yeah all right don't go
nowhere okay all right
all right did you hear all that
so y'all want them
downtown yo not true okay yeah so it's
gonna be hard it didn't happen in
Choctaw school but yeah all right we're
taking
his car all right
all right I got you all right
all right
all right I'm gonna get a statement form
how did this guy start filling it out so
all right bye
I got a scarf
you got one I said I'll get this car for
you guys
tow his car for you oh okay well I'll
start one here in a little bit
first
all right turn around and face the other
way all right be on your back
you're under arrest for impersonating
law enforcement all right
and then you also have a charge for
transporting an open container
uh not at this time
you know how long I'm gonna be in jail
because
well your mom lives here so well I know
that I'm not too worried about that well
I mean
go ahead and step on it I'm gonna double
check make sure you don't have anything
in your pockets or not
place the Tahoe here
you got a vape yeah
your right pocket yeah okay
all right everyone
she used to work in a jail yeah so you
know what what goes down in jail you
know you know the process a little bit
yeah
right okay go ahead and have a seat back
in there
I don't know yeah man
251 County Sherwood Maryland
uh let's get a statement from both of
them just we'll have that much
I'll give you a statement form for us to
give to him
and I had a feeling that this was
the professionally
not here all right
[Music]
on that
thank you
I didn't hear you I'm just trying I'm
just trying to be nice
okay you'll be able to make a phone call
when you get to the job I don't know
anybody we'll be able to give you phone
numbers we'll write down phone numbers
for you and you'll have a piece of paper
with their number did you talk to my
your cousin Jacob yep
uh he doesn't know you're going to jail
because we didn't confirm what we know
now until we talk to the RP so huh
reporting party
okay well that's because you're not long
long questions all right
um but Jacob wanted me to let you know
that if you try to come back there and
get a job you won't be hired okay
so usually so since it's your first
defense going to jail right okay don't
and I'm from Tennessee it's I don't
usually I shouldn't be in jail that long
I should be on it's all up to the judge
on that and whether or not you have the
ability to bond out financially all too
long on Mondays possibly
okay
uh it depends on if you bond out
once you get in and get booked in there
will be a bond amount that'll be set and
then if you can bond out with the
bondsman or whatever somebody pays me
all the way from Tennessee well they'll
have to get with the bondsman here make
a payment to the bondsman and the
bondsman yeah
all right
how's it going
better every day
all
righty if you will put all your
information on there and then when you
start talking about the traffic stop
working stopped you and stuff like that
put real good information in there like
the exact location where he made contact
with you where he where you initially
seen him and everything and I want to
confirm right now everything happened in
Oklahoma County right
okay
when when you first seen him he was in
Lincoln County yeah and then he followed
you into Hera yes and made made contact
with you in here yes you know where that
platform is like you're going off 62
like you're going like yeah yeah County
Line Road right there you got that pig
farm
on top of the hill it's a the Hera
agbarn
on the south side of 62 or yeah okay I
kind of know the area of 62 in pot
County Road y'all top that hill and you
start going down the hill there's a
little dirt road that goes to your left
that's where he's sitting on not on our
dark because I live on dirt road it was
on the house right next door on the dirt
road on inner driveway cockeyed but
where he made contact with you and he
stated he was law enforcement was at
Sonic at Sonic yeah because he pulled up
right behind me and I was like
first thing ever yeah and when he did
tell me that I was like
yeah and then he told me his partner was
a uh
uh
Wellston uh he's out of Wellston and his
uh partner is a highway patrolman
I was like all right yeah put all that
in there and even put on there when
you've seen him turn around and flashing
his headlights at somebody all right
found any guns yet but I haven't done
like a thorough search of his car yet
because he had a gun on the side he did
have a gun on his side oh you've seen
him yeah in a holster yeah okay and he
had handcuffs yeah yeah I mean just like
just like you had one thing he even had
was a body Cam and then right here on
his chest right here it just said sure
right that was it I got pictures of that
yeah uh so when we made contact with him
he doesn't have a firearm on him but
that doesn't mean it's not in the car
and then uh he told me yeah let me go
because he got a call that's why he let
me go out of Sonic because he goes well
because then they flipped the UE on
someone and was flashing their life
right pass over the uh Interstate the uh
right wing pass underneath it he put the
yui it was going back towards you know
the turn Going Back East yeah and so our
classic lights up that car I was like
and then I got home I just got home
because we're coming back to AutoZone
and get some parts for our car and then
uh that's my boy I was like man this is
kind of strange my car was sitting in
the driveway and I wish you would have
called it in way earlier but I'm glad we
got him though and then I was thinking
yeah I was sitting there thinking if
he's Oklahoma County they don't cross
over into Lincoln County and Lincoln
County does not cross over to Oklahoma
County we might go over there to help
them with something exactly but one of
them is going to be there with is that
because y'all don't station by yourself
it's what's on over in Lincoln County if
you're a comical all right and that's
what cotton and uh my wife's like you
better call somebody and see what's
going on because that's just very very
strange yeah
a flash of Lights at me nothing he just
got light on my all right on my bumper
man and it just followed me into town I
was like
it's kind of weird I'm gonna be pulling
Sonic to see what man if he's gonna pull
that with me right when he pulled in he
caught his car right in behind mine yeah
right right okay good I'm glad you came
over here and told us because that
sealed the deal because we were gonna
let him go oh shit because prior to that
we we didn't have any like solid uh
stuff on them but thank you for coming
back over here uh if you want to work on
that try to write as legibly as you can
because I'm not very confused because I
really possibly I can take about 30
minutes you can take your time because
my wife I take it home my wife and I can
tell her to show about accounts exactly
what I support my word how far is home
from here
right
yeah is it in Oklahoma County it's in
Lincoln County it's in Lincoln County
it's right on there on the Lincoln in
Oklahoma County High
on the line
let me get your and I'm not
I'm not a very good speller at all and
my wife see how about you can you run
pretty good
it just needs to be legible just so I
can attach it to the charge package it
just has to be legible to where I can
make out enough or judge can make out
enough that way you know because I can
tell my wife deboped by detail and she
can write down perfect because I mean
we're not very good spellers at all but
I've got I don't care about spelling as
long as as long as we can tell what
you're saying yeah that is the biggest
deal so just
I'd like you to fill it out right here
and just write as slow as you have to
just to make it to where I can read it
as much as possible all right so I like
playing all right all right sound like
playing
uh signature okay all right and then
when you're done sign the bottom all
right all right thanks
all right
yeah if you got all of his information
he's good to go
did you say something
do what
it's evidence yeah
you want you're wanting your phone to go
with you
and your ID
I can bring the cash with you it'll be
booked in
uh but you'll they'll have it like on
your books so if you're there but then
if you end up bonding out or getting out
getting released they'll give you a
check for whatever that amount is
the food from McDonald's is that what
you're saying it's taught me before you
got your food oh well hey
I mean
real quick before you came together I'll
see if he can I'll see if he can get
that worked out
your wallet's still in the car uh yeah
it should be in the city
okay all right we'll get it
uh the only request he has is uh because
he already paid for his meal
I was hoping maybe you can get his money
back if he didn't get his meal
I figured that wouldn't be
anything
just because I can't really read his
handwriting right after we wrote his
name I just wrote down right there okay
that's the phone number that he called
to get a hold of
Royce
we have a Dylan Peterson works for us
if things were just like we're adding up
and then that guy pulled up at just a
ride home I was like thank you for
coming over here
no no we're gonna impound it
all right
the guy in the SUV says he had a gun
all right I got his wallet
if you spot it just let it lay
there's probably gonna be close to him
unless he got out and put it in the
trunk
Campbell County High School
what'd you say
huh
I wonder if that's when he applied for
assistance
so how much
that might be the change from it you got
two dollars and 24 cents in change and
it would cost five it costs uh okay
yeah there's another bottle
we've been living in this car
wow
I did see feminine products
foreign
I mean that's not to say he didn't
take it off
all right
foreign
on the ground
Five Guys
25 pound him back in they're gonna go
take care of their fence over there
I was thinking he was going to say that
he was Oklahoma County and that's why I
came over here
17 years
I'll have a pretty good idea if he's
been in or around the county in the last
10-12 years
should recognize them unless he happens
to be one of those reserves that wasn't
very active
anyways just because I was like man I
don't know if this guy's gonna have
what are we doing right and to not have
any kind of formal
identification for
for the agency
checked everything on that
thank you
all right
okay
thank you
foreign
all right they're working on getting
your money from McDonald's did you want
the cash that was in the car
you want to leave it in the car
yeah it's getting impacted
Okay so
so she'll have to show proof of
ownership
so if you get bonded out or whatever
then you'll be able to get it out
okay as long as we don't place a hold on
it for investigative purposes okay I
mean I wasn't really good enough
with the car I mean there's nothing
Place stuff in it like police
interceptor
oh that's fun no lights you know I mean
okay yeah okay
all right got it
three dollars
uh I'll take them just in case I mean
I'll I'll give them put them with his
property
find me as important idea in effect
was there anything prior to me getting
here that
yeah
no I just started talking to him
that's what I kind of thought
right
okay yeah I think I'm good
I mean you don't look old enough for 17
years I'm 38. you're only like five
years old
I started in the jail
20 or 19. I graduated high school I was
19.
graduated in 2004 started counting in
2005.
so
all right
yeah if you want to cut out I'm going to
start a record and then once I got get
done with their statement then I'm going
to head to the county jail okay all
right
you're waiting on their statement anyway
yeah I'm just gonna hang out
with a statement and I'm going to start
a record
well I appreciate it sir no problem
thank you
for Baker Mary Mary 6169 Tennessee
we're in the parking lot of the
fish in the next McDonald's
sir
all right
you'll be at the Oklahoma County
Detention Center who's that
um
it's our detention center it's our jail
the way it's pretty good size you know
yeah a lot of people that go to prison
say it's the worst place to be
called McDonald's yeah
it's not a good place
I walked into jail
our County just sucks
oh this one's big a lot of people
six like six like that we have uh we
have 200 cells on the floor and we've
got 13 floors
probably not all right so that's
different from mine
it's a one door and you walk in
everybody's in the playroom and then you
got we got slider doors that go into a
big day room and there's cells that lie
in the wall all the way around and
that's just one pod and there's four
pods on each floor
and there's 13
. I just go I mean I'm not I don't want
to get no trouble
it's it's a serious deal when you're
impersonating a police officer so well I
know like I don't know how long it is I
mean first I mean since I don't have any
criminal records I mean yeah it'll be up
to the judge to decide that all right
all right
hold on I can't hear you
you know you know can you tell me the
address like where he's taking the Kia
I'm gonna give you a toe slip or a piece
of paper with the tow truck company's
information
okay you're not losing the car forever
all right so like when I get out of jail
yeah
all right
foreign